hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from this year's bundesliga
uh a lot of you have requested it as
it's
it's just a very crazy game uh you know
it's not a not a one-sided game both
players are
doing awesome stuff in this game uh and
it's a game between swiss grandmaster
noah studa
not really sure how to pronounce swiss
names so i'm going to go with with the
german pronunciation
uh and uh of course hungarian
grandmaster richard rapport
and um it's been a while since we had a
classical game and in bundesliga all of
the games are of the classical time
format so
it's going to be pretty wild uh so
without further ado uh let's check it
out
and uh since this is uh also covered by
the grinky chess classic
chess channel uh by the by the video
team behind the grand khs classic uh
also there is an impression video after
every round
so i will include a few of those videos
in the description below first thing you
you will see uh so you can see a lot of
high quality footage of a lot of
very strong grand masters if you guys
are interested in that
so let's check it out with the white
pieces
opens with d4 we have d5 by rapport and
c4 now with e6 knight to f3 and c6 going
for the slav defense with
knight b to d2 this is actually somewhat
rarer but also very popular in 2020
usually you'd see something like e3
queen to c2
maybe knights the c3 here but knight bd2
also very popular in 2020
and here f5 going for sort of a
stonewall
dutch kind of setup here
we have g3 and knight b to d7 now
bishop to g2 and now knights the h6 so a
very
uh you know very interesting development
of the knights this knight is coming to
f7 and then you want to push
g5 and then have the option of g4 f4 and
so on
uh and there's only one game that has
reached this position ever it was again
blanco right
versus thomas markowski in 1999 that
ended in a draw but
in that game castles was played by
kuraitsa and here we have queen to c2
so already as of move seven uh we have a
completely new game
uh rapper continues with his plan knight
f7
uh preparing g5 and b3 here
uh we have g5 and now e3 uh we have
bishop to d6 continuing development and
bishop to b2 now uh at some point if
this diagonal opens up
it's going to be very good for this
bishop also goes goes for the light
square bishop we have
a5 and now h4 uh
asking black what do you want to do here
do will you allow me to open up
the h file for my rook or do you want to
maybe push g4
and here rapper goes g4 which pushes the
knight all the way back but this is only
temporary
as this knight will uh find its way all
the way to f4 now that you've played
g4 you weaken the f4 square which will
now
become an excellent outpost for uh for
students knight
uh we have castles by rapport and knight
to e2 going after that
f4 square with knight to f6 and now
knight to f4 and this is now
a beautiful piece uh black doesn't have
a g pawn to kick it away you will never
be able to play e5 because you will
weaken the d5 uh
pawn too much so that knight is here to
stay or
rather until black decides to trade one
of its pieces for it in here
we have queen to e7 developing the queen
uh we have castles by study and now
knight the h8 preparing
to bring this knight over to g6 to
eliminate uh
white's excellent knight on f4 uh we
have c5 here
uh white wants to play on the queen side
that's why he plays this
somewhat anti-positional move he wants
to play a3 and b4
uh we have bishop to c7 and now a3
continuing with the plan of b4
knight to g6 now uh preparing to capture
this knight
and b4 we have finally knight captures
we have e
captures and now knight the h5 and this
knight to h5
is a is an excellent move uh
preparing uh well just preparing a
sacrifice of the knight on f4 and
there's not much white can do about it
why can't simply prepare for it
and try to endure the pressure because
uh if you look at it
uh black has these very advanced pawns
something you might see for example in a
king's indian defense and
white's bishops aren't doing uh all that
much here i mean dubai
both white and dark square bishop are
pretty much uh just you know hitting
blanks
uh and black uh can well black can
afford to sacrifice one of the pieces to
to push and you will capture for example
here here
uh sorry you will eliminate this then
you will be able to capture here maybe
you can bring uh maybe you can bring a
rook into the attack as well
uh a lot of things are possible here and
here uh student
prepares for it with rook to e1 and now
rapper goes for it
knight captures on f4 we have g captures
and now it's a question do you capture
with the bishop or do you capture with
the queen
now uh in human terms seems to be all
the same
the engine prefers uh queen captures on
h4 uh
slightly more but you know engines are
are weird
uh but i i'm going to tell you why queen
queen h4 is preferred
uh it's because of rook to e1 that's why
you should play queen to h4 first
because
uh white has a defensive idea which
involves knight to c4 and
if you go queen to h4 it doesn't work uh
all that great but we're going to show
that
because the queen captures on h4 white's
idea of
giving up the knight to free up this
dark square bishop and
to create a mating attack uh will not be
all that uh possible because now after
the capture and the d5 there is no queen
here so black will have the option of
capturing with the e pawn but just to
give you an idea of how crazy the
position is
captures uh with the c pawn white also
gives up the light square bishop
captures and now queen to c3 threatening
queen g7 checkmate and here you don't
have a
good escape you cannot escape with the
king because the rook covers the entire
e file so queen g7 will be checkmate
uh so here you would have to give up the
queen and the rook with captures
captures and captures and
now we have this position king f7 rook
e7 check trading for example the bishops
and now a captures on b4 and now it's a
crazy position
uh white is up the exchange but black
has all of these pawns and
uh well if anyone is to be preferred
here it's black
and that's why in this crazy position
after this capture queen captures on h4
is preferred to bishop captures on f4
but a rapper goes for bishop captures on
f4 instead
and now the zed line is a bit stronger
knight to c4
now if captures then d5 is a bit
stronger you will never have ed5 because
uh
well the queen is still on e7 but it
could still be played however
uh we have queen captures on h4 he just
leaves the knight there and
allows the knights to infiltrate with
knight to b6
which is what student does we have
knight to b6 and now
uh there are a lot of moves you can play
here like you have to
see what happens after bishop check
queen check
you could just maybe decide to save the
rook but rapper decides to play in great
style
hence the the quote above the board from
the great misha himself
and he goes e5 and now e5
uh used to free up the uh the diagonal
for this light square bishop at some
point uh
offers even more material so what
what the idea is that if for example e
captures on d5 now you go bishop h2
check
king f1 and now f4 with the idea of f3
and at some point white has to play it
f3 and now bishop to f5 it gets another
piece into the attack
and now uh regardless of what the engine
says the engine might even prefer white
here
and i i do believe uh it does uh it's
gonna be
i mean uh playing this with black is
just very satisfying and
it's very natural to play this uh even
though the the engine could probably
hold it
uh so that's one thing that can happen
if you capture the rook that's a bit too
greedy that just runs into
into hell for example bishop h2 checking
f1 f4 with the same idea
but now f3 you've wasted a move there
with the knight you're gonna get
e4 now this this pawn survived and it's
gonna be crazy captures f3
and you you just fall apart bishop h1
queen g3 threatening checkmate
as the pawn covers the e2 square and
there's no defense if you try and block
it just queen h3 check
and here let's say this check opens up
the rook and it's game over
so after e5 uh white decided
uh to open up uh open up uh
the the well diagonals and the files
leading to the black king
so knight captures on d5 he wants to get
this bishop uh here
and of course he wants to get the other
bishop fully operational
so can this be done uh we have knight
captures
uh sorry uh after knight captures on d5
uh we have uh
bone captures on d5 and now uh you have
to play bishop captures on d5 with
check and now uh well the bishop pair is
almost fully operational
however after the c captures on d5 uh
study played
rook capture 7e5 and now what do you do
here
well his idea is of course that he wants
to eliminate one of rapport's attackers
after bishop captures and now for
example bishop captures on d5 checking
g7 and this capture here
now you're ready to open up all of the
diagonals play
e6 e7 maybe and uh
try and uh try and do something about it
as you've eliminated uh the
black's dark square bishop which is a
very important attacker
this light square bishop doesn't really
have a clear way of entering the game
and it's going to be it's going to be
tougher black but it will be possible
for example 8 characters on b4
that is a very very nice move for black
because you either get to trade down
material or
you get a very important tempo
preventing this check for example king
g6 and queen c3 because the pawn out
takes
away the c3 square from from the white
queen so it is a very important
uh in-between move but after rook
captures an e5 we first have
bishop to h2 check uh now throwing in
this one check
we have king to f1 and only now bishop
captures uh on e5
so how is it any different now that the
king is on f1
well we have bishop captures on d5 with
check
kink to g7 and now d captures on e5
and now rapper goes eight captures on b4
like we said this is
incredibly important as you either get
to trade down even further or
you just cover the c3 square which is uh
where the white queen wants to go
and here e6 king g6 the the black king
is remarkably safe here on g6 like i
said
you don't have queen to c3 just yet so
uh it's uh
it's gonna be it's not all that clear
how you how you can increase the
pressure here
so instead after eight characters on v4
uh
decided to uh get his king
to safety but uh the king is not all
that much safer here
now just capturing an a3 is is
sufficient for
upward but rapport continues with uh
with
well with great style rook captures on
a3
now rook captures an a3 is very flashy
but it allows uh
it allows white to you know to kind of
maybe defend
but it's uh that's the point of this
game like uh you know the deep dark
forest and everything
uh so for example e6 check king g6 and
now bishop captures
captures captures and now the rook might
be a very important defender and
attacker here
so it's uh questionable if this is uh
this rook sacrifice is the way to go
uh however student uh captured it right
away we have b
captures and now queen to c3 uh finally
uh study to open up this diagonal
but rapport says no that's completely
fine f4 we're just continuing the attack
my king will be super safe here on g6
so rook captures on a3 adding another
defender to the third rank and
now f3 with check with king the e3
and now queen to g5 with check so where
do you go with the king we have king d3
and now rook to d8 attacking that bishop
here
and now it doesn't really matter what
you do
because there's not much you can do
white played queen to d4 defending the
bishop
but now feel free to pause the video and
win this game in the simplest way
possible for rapper
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on uh attacking the
pin piece
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's a bishop to e6 this
is what rapper played and it was in this
position on unmoved 35 that
no the uh resigned the game as there is
nothing
more to be done here you just lose the
piece and that's it
uh it doesn't really matter if you try
king to c4 here it's all the same
queen f4 check you have to move the king
and you lose the bishop
or you block with the queen but then it
just captures captures and again bishop
to e6 which makes it even simpler as now
the queens are over the board you're
just going to be up a piece so
completely winning of course
so brilliant victory as they say it
takes two to create a
to create a beautiful game and these two
definitely have created it that richard
rapport
comes up on top uh and he wins this game
and he was a
a member of the baden baden team that
also won bundesliga
led that led by fabian quran and maxine
vashir lagrave and levan arun
uh uh and a lot of very very strong
grandmasters so they win
again as i understand that they win
pretty much every year
uh and yeah like i said uh if you if you
enjoy watching extreme
high quality footage of grand masters do
check it out i will put some links in
the description below
so you know yeah you can enjoy that as
well uh i would like to thank uh
thomas knob mata um reichenbach peter
waddek
marco lepocic and kevin walker for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens
in the chess world so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day